hey what's going on guys I'm Jade
warshaw one of the co-hosts of the
Ramsey Show look we're always telling
you the most fun that you can have with
money is to give it so we are going to
put that to the test we went over to our
local Kroger grocery store and we're
going to see just how fun it is to give
some money away I think I just want to
buy you guys' groceries today yes are
you kidding we have a really cool
Christmas basket over here that we'd
like you guys to just fill up with
whatever you want we are filling these
carts up this is so fun my kid uses
these my baby eats these yes get plenty
for the baby I know things I've been
wanting to buy and haden't been able to
bad yes look she's doing the right thing
she's just throwing it in the
cart this is
great all right two weeks of groceries
for 388
75 this season if you haven't had a
chance go and give go bless someone's
life it will truly be the most fun you
can ever have with money